this is Blake Graham triple diamond with
youngevity here with Dr Joel Wallock the
Dr wallik and we're here to talk today
about the principle of absorption we
know that with nutrition it's not what
you consume that counts it's what you
absorb right right it used to be said
you are what you heat but that's not
really true it's what you absorb you are
what you absorb and I know that's one of
the things that makes your supplements
really stand out is because they're so
easy for the body to absorb but let's
talk first about how absorption works in
the body tell us about kind of the gast
intestinal system how it is that our
body is supposed to break down food okay
well digestion actually starts in the
mouth most people don't realize it but
digestion starts in the mouth two ways
one mechanical grinding and breaking up
and chewing is very important getting
pieces smaller and smaller and smaller
in fact the human body is a juice
machine everything is is moving towards
being Juiced right so we're going to
chew things up chop things up into a
small swallowable pieces and saliva
actually has Tylen in it which is a
carbohydrate busting enzyme and actually
begins to break down carbohydrate into
sugars and sugars into simple sugars and
so on and so digestion begins in the
mouth it goes down the S of the stomach
and the pH Chang from an alkal
environment which is in the mouth to a
very acid environment your stomach has
to be a pH of one in a PH range of one
being the most acid seven being neutral
and 14 being the most alkaline it's
imperative that your stomach environment
be acid for several reasons number one
it sterilizes the stomach so yeast and
bacteria don't grow there and prevents
the formation and fermentation of
carbohydrates and sugars and fiber into
gases and which causes bloating and
reflux heartburn and all that nasty
stuff also the enzyme pepsin which is
produced by the stomach requires a acid
environment to function properly pepsin
is the protein digesting enzyme it
breaks down uh animal flesh proteins
plant proteins including grains eggs and
so forth cheese es milk any proteins are
broken down into the simplest of amino
acids by pepsin in the stomach the acid
environment is also required for a
substance called Castle intrinsic factor
which is produced by the stomach wall to
bind with vitamin B12 and absorb bottom
B12 you cannot absorb bottom B12 without
the being um first very seriously
acidified the intrinsic factor just
won't work there are cells in the lining
of the stomach that actually make the
stomach ASD hydroc choric acid is
they're called Chief cells and these
Chief cells require sodium chloride as a
ra material to make hydrochloric acid so
that's kind of what goes on in the
stomach uh when the stomach turns things
around continues this mechanical
breaking down the acid begins to break
down um food by actually dissolving the
connective tissue and separating fibers
and cells of your food and then of
course there's the pepsin digestive
enzymes which break down the proteins
into polypeptides long strings of amino
acids down to tripeptides which are
three amino acids diopsides which are
two amino acids the goal is to get down
to the simplist amino acids which makes
protein digestion absorption easier then
as the food moves into the duodenum some
people say dadum but dadum is how I
learned it the pancreas and liver both
empty into the common bile duct which
then empties into the duum and the
pancreas actually produces quartz of
alkal izing mucus and um bicarbonate in
the form of bicarbonate the purpose is
to alkalize the do a denal environment
because the pancreatic enzymes and the
intestinal enzymes only work in an
alkaline environment so you got to
switch from being very very acid very
alkaline so all enzymes are very pH
dependent absolutely they work on a
certain PH range and if you get out of
that PH range those enzymes aren't as
effective well they become a non-factor
they're just zero they will not work if
they're not in the right PH range and
this is why we die from changes in PH of
our cells uh the enzymes in our cells
don't work either not only the digestive
system outside their PH range and if you
get into acidosis and normally our body
itself is supposed to be like
7.1 and pH just a little above neutral
and you get to be 7.3 in what's called
alkalosis you're in the hospital dime
because they all your enzymes and your
cell stop it's too too high of a pH if
you if you get down to say 6.9 or 6.8
below neutral you're on the acid side
you're in acidoses you're in the
hospital dime because the enzymes can't
work in an acid environment either so
we've got very strong acid environment
in the stomach but then once we get into
the small intestine the body actually
shifts the pH levels changes the
environment because we have different
enzymes going to work yes you have a
whole plethora I guess is the word that
Sher uses okay a whole plethora of
enzymes that are produced by the
pancreas to digest
proteins again to digest carbohydrates
down from long chains hundreds of sugars
down to polysaccharides or disaccharides
which are multiples of sugars Two Sugars
down to simple sugars and break down uh
complex sugars into simple sugars it
also has uh lipases all the enzymes that
are produced by the pancreas end in the
suffix Ace AE and so if there's a pep
peptase you know you're that's a
pancreatic enzyme like lactase we hear
about for breaking down lactose exactly
so all the ace means they're pancreatic
enzymes that are digesting long chains
of things down in their simplest
components for absorption down the pike
and once we break them down then we
still have to absorb them how how does
that work in the int we got one more
piece going on here and that is the bile
coming down the bile duck which is
produced by the liver the largest gland
in the body is designed to do two things
number one homogenized fats take them
from big large molecules of fat down to
little droplets in a very uniform
fashion purpose of which is to absorb
fats so when the fats are attached to
bile salts you absorb these fats easier
you go from large fats down to fatty
acids okay or or triglycerides which is
a three carbon glycer all with three
long chains of fat on it triglycerides
that's where that comes from and so the
bile breaks all that down into the
simplest of fats called fatty acids then
the bile also helps you absorb fat
salable vitamins a d e and K also the
bile uh from the liver helps you absorb
cholesterol the good fats very important
to everything from your cell walls to
your brain to nerve
insulation and storage of energy and so
on then as this whole is kind of a soup
at this point it's called Kim CH H yme
and this soup moves down the intestine
to where if the stomach and the dadum or
dadum and the pancreas and the liver and
the bile have done their job now you
just have this soup moving down the
intestines and instead of just being a
smooth tube the in the intestinal
absorptive surface is magnified like 85
Times by these finger like Villi which
stick up and it looks like velvet when
you open up an intestine with a knife
and you look at with a naked eye at the
intestine but when you look at it under
the microscope this velvet is actually
uh produced by finger like Villi uh
which have little blood vessels up in
them which then get the blood closer to
the surface of the cells in the
intestines so when you absorb this um
the molecules now of fat and proteins or
amino acids and fatty acids and simple
sugars goes through one cell and the
intestine right into these little blood
vessels little capillaries if you will
then into the bloodstream which then
goes up the hepatic vein in through the
liver for the most part and the liver
pulls out what it wants and then
distributes everything else when we talk
about these Villa I've seen slides and
it looks like almost like imagining a
visual of carpet fibers right and on
each of these carpet fibers then there
are individual hairs that stick micro
that actually again you said increase
the surface area of the Su by 85 fold
yes that's
and also they have a certain amount of
muscle in them so that there's this
pistolic waves of the muscle in the
intestine squeezing things along just
like you would you know take one of
these uh large long balloons and You'
take your fingers you would just kind of
move um say the narrow part of it down
you can you know how these magicians do
that with the uh these long balloons
make little animals and Things by moving
the narrow piece up and down the balloon
uh with their hands well the muscles in
the sto uh the stomach do that the
muscles and the intestinal walls do that
and the muscles and these little Villi
do that additionally there's a wave like
Motion in addition to this large
muscular motion there's also this wave
like motion of these Villi that move
things along and also it opens up the
space between the Villi so more stuff
more this K can get down in between them
and be exposed to the surface area now
is that why when people have
inflammation it really decreases the
absorption area they get inflamed and
food can't get down between there and
correct that's one of the things that
happens when you have inflammation for
any reason whether you have an infection
like Sal Manila you know Sal you get a
Salona infection or you get food
poisoning and everything comes out the
other end because you can't absorb it
the these little Villi swell as you can
imagine they swell and it closes off
that space in between them as you point
out and even the tips of them get all
inflamed and and swollen and so they
cannot perform their function more
absorption is reduced to almost zero at
that point now what's the role of the
good bacteria in our intestinal track
what does that do for our bodies well
the good bacteria 99.9% of them are in
the colon they're not in the stomach
which is sterile if you have the right
amount of acid they're not found in the
small intestine if you have the right
amount of alkali and so the good
bacteria kind of survive I mean let's
say you swallow a million probiotics
maybe only 20,000 get through your
stomach because the acid kills them all
right okay then out of the 20,000 gets
into your small intestines maybe another
10,000 die
uh because of the alkaline environment
so that maybe only 10,000 make it your
colon but when they get there that's the
perfect environment for them pH wise uh
oxygen wise and so forth and they begin
to flourish and reproduce themselves and
10,000 become billions and what do they
do well they actually fend off bad
bacteria by just being there and growing
their presence they're called commensals
they're just there most of them don't
produce any good for us but their
presence crowds out the bad guys there's
also a symbiotic relationship with some
of these probiotics in that they produce
vitamin C they produce vitamin B12 they
do all kinds of nifty stuff by producing
certain vitamins and this is this
actually happens in animals in their
digestive tracts as well I always smile
when vegetarians say well look there's a
cow and an elephant they eat grass and
look at them why can't we just eat
vegetables well when you look at a cow
or a deer or an animal
the these are four stomach animals moose
and Yaks and very large um four
stomached animals there's probably a
reason why they have four stomachs well
if you think about if you look around
the world what is the most other than
rodents uh what is the most common
vertebrae you see other than human
beings around the earth four stomach
animals every continent has four
stomached animals whereas uh elepants
are in a very micro environment right
liines and tigers are in micro
environments monkeys are in micro
environments but these four stomach
animals ruminants as are called are
found in every environment of the world
there's actually musk up above the
Arctic Circle and you have all these
hundreds of different antelopes in
Africa and you got uh many species of
deer and moose and wild sheep and goats
in North America cattle cattle there's
wild cattle all over the place
especially in Asia and they've been
domesticated and wild goats and wild
sheep and so these things are very
Universal because they're able to digest
things that nothing else can digest they
can take grass which is essentially
useless to all animals but what they do
is there's a big there's four stomachs
and the first two are kind of
mechanically breaking things down but
the third stomach is called the rumin
and in a cow it's it contains 40 gallons
of fluid and it's a big fermentative
that it's kind of like making beer in
there right and remember I say our whole
digestive system is a juice machine
making things into juice well a cow has
this big 40 gallon rumin Ru Meen UM
fermentative Vet is full of bacteria and
yeast and fungus and viruses and
protozoa now what's the difference
between a protozoa and a bacteria well a
bacteria are plants protozoan are
animals they have little Villi like
little ores in a boat and and they move
around with these little Villi and they
consciously move from here to there and
they have pumps that move things around
they're little animals and so it's this
big vet that's breaking down the grass
so that the cow can access the nutrients
in that's correct and that's a
simplistic way of putting it it's more
complex than that in that the enzymes
produced by the bacteria and the fungus
and the yeast break down the grass which
is cellulose primarily like heavy fiber
and it breaks it down into carbohydrates
and complex sugars and then simple
sugars well then other bacteria take
those simple sugars and ferment them and
add nitrogen to them and turn them into
amino acids what happens now here's
these parium these protozoa which are an
animal not bacteria not plants and so
now these protozoa these little animals
can actually take these amino acids and
turn them into protein for themselves
okay then they also can take inorganic
minerals and convert them the bacteria
turn them into chelated minerals which
are inorganic minerals that they're
combined with the amino acids right now
these little protozoa can use them
minerals for themselves and then the cow
eats the little animal right goes into
the fourth stomach so in the end the cow
is a carnivore the cow is eating little
animals in the four stomach called an
abom Mason so the cow is eating grass to
feed the little animals yes you now you
got it all right and that's why the
theory of vegetarians is incorrect okay
because we cannot survive eating
vegetables okay so cows and all
ruminants ruminants whether they're a
giraffe or a wild cow or sheep or goat
or deer or moose or Yak or um MUSC or
any of these four stomached animals the
common thing is you hit it exactly right
they're they're eating this grass to
feed the little animals which they then
eat wow and we know from your Dead
Doctors Don't Lie audio cassette that
having those chelated minerals are so
important because inorganic minerals we
just don't absorb exactly inorganic
minerals even for Animals you know they
eat clay and all the kind of stuff again
to feed these little animals with inside
of them and inorganic minerals are only
usable 3 to 5% 3 to 10%
and the four stomach animals do a little
better job than the single stomach
animals like monkeys and horses and
things like that and you and I of course
and um this is why in crossing the
Prairie it was much more efficient to
use oxen big large teams of oxen pulling
the wagons because in horses because
they if they use horses they had to
carry extra wagons hauling grain to feed
the horses they couldn't survive just
eating the Prairie Grass where the oxen
could because of the four stomachs well
it's like the Eco cars we talk about you
know they can get further uh on less
fuel essentially because you don't have
to carry fuel around with them with the
oxidant exactly so in the human
digestive tract then since we don't have
the four stomachs we obviously have to
have food that's uh from various sources
because we can't break down the grass
but when we get to the colon with a good
bacteria there is there anything else
that we need to know about what that
good bacteria does and I'd like you to
mention a little bit about the appendix
because most of of us have been taught
that the appendix is just you know
something in there that we don't know
what it's good for you know maybe the
good Lord put it in there so surgeons
would have something to take out right
well that's what they think I'm sure but
I know that there's a reason for sure
well there's multiples reasons but um
one of the main ones is you've all heard
of te- cells right right te- cells te-
cells are activated by the thymus gland
that's why they're called tea cells t
for thymus yeah often killer tea cells
are part of the IM system you got it and
they can't function until they're
activated the switch is turned on when
they flow through the thymus okay that's
why they're called te- cells and if you
surgically remove your thymus or you
kill it with radiation you'll never have
active te cells you'll have lots of te-
cells but they won't be activated and
can't do anything of any consequence for
for your immune system well there's
another set of white blood cells that
attack foreign invading bacteria viruses
and fungus and things cancer cells
they're called B cells and they're
activated by the appendix well wait a
minute if you have te- cells are
activated theum you can understand t for
thymus t for t- cells why would you have
the appendix activating B cells well
that's because they first realized this
in the Bersa of facius in chickens which
is the appendix in chickens called the
Bersa of fous a fellow by the name of
Fus figured it out that these cells
these defensive white blood cells are
activated by the burst of fasis in the
chickens and so he called them B cell
for Bersa okay so if somebody doesn't
have their opic cuz you cannot activate
the B cells and you lose a significant
portion of your immune system when we
need to make sure that the nutrients get
absorbed in the body then we need to
look at our body's ability to digest it
and since it starts in the mouth and in
the stomach and we need an acid
environment what are some of the things
that our bodies need to produce acid now
you mentioned like we need NAC table
salt right na right and chemically HCL
hydrochloric acid has the same chloride
ion that salt does right so do we need
to have salt in our diet in order to
make hydrochloric acid Blake it's an
essential nutrient you cannot live
without sodium chloride anybody who says
you need to restrict salt should be put
in jail for reckless endangerment this
is what acidifies your stomach and
people who do not consume salt will set
themselves up for many many many
diseases and increase their risk of
allergies because you can't break down
proteins in the simplest of amino acids
these dipeptides to amino acids
tripeptides polypeptides multiples amino
acids
become allergens you're you can absorb
them in your bloodstream but your body
recognizes them as oranges or beef or
eggs and so what happens is you get
allergic to those Foods when you cannot
fully digest them down to the simplest
of amino acids they're treated like
foreign Invaders exactly so it's a real
Hazard and so it's imperative that you
have stomach acid there's actually
specialized cells in the stomach called
Chief cells you actually recognize them
on microscopic session of the stomach
they they're very distinctive and very
separate from the just a standard uh
cells in the stomach like I say
imperative nothing happens and also
acidifies the minerals for instance you
can be supplementing with all the iron
you want I mean with tons of iron and
you can still be iron deficient if you
don't have enough stomach acid to then
acidify that iron so that it uh is
usable absorbable in the body just like
we said before it's not what you eat
it's what you absorb the counts exactly
right now we have more and more problem
with uh a lot of people with digestive
issues and that's the title of this
recording here serial killers we call it
Cal not like cial with an S like a
repeat but serial with the sea like the
grains um and that's because we're
seeing an increase in the amount of a
lot of these grains and cereals in our
diet I think the World Health
Organization actually did a study and
they looked at the number of increasing
the carbohydrates in our carbohydrates
have more than doubled over the last few
decades and 85% of that is in inrease in
those breakfast cereals right and so
when we're getting more and more cereals
and more and more grains in the body
especially we talk about wheat barley
Ryan OES and I know there are some
people that talk about uh hybridization
you know I know in farming technique
you're an expert in agriculture as well
there was a time when the farmers and
agriculture actually looked at
hybridizing wheat so we get a more
robust wheat that'll grow in a lot of
different environments a shorter grain
stock to increase yield but it's not
just having a more robust weed it's
actually the body's ability to break it
down and the decrease of the salt in the
diet because more and more people are
saying Hey low salt low salt low salt
because we've heard about it from
doctors what does that do when we have
more grains and we've decreased the
body's ability to break it down well
that's about 16
questions and so basically you have to
appreciate that the hybridization of all
things in agriculture is designed to
increase yields uh more as you say you
word more robust and able to fend off
enemies like bugs and smut which is like
fungus and things of that nature growing
environments where it couldn't grow
before maybe but also what happens is
you give up something when you hybridize
okay a plant anytime you inbreed it or
hybridize it you're giving up something
to get something in the case of uh
better defenses defend off again yeast
and bacteria and fungus and viruses that
attack the plant so you don't have to
use pesticides you're able to grow them
in a more organic sort of way you're
avoiding more chemicals by so there's
not it's it's not intended to be a bad
thing to hybridize them because if you
build a plant that can fend off bugs and
bacteria and viruses without the use of
chemicals that's very good right
unfortunately there's always unintended
consequences one of the unintended
consequences of hybridizing wheat for
instance is the reduction in protein uh
back at the turn of the 20th century
depending on the strain of wheat the
species of wheat you had anywhere from
13 to 17% protein well today it's about
3% protein so the amount of protein goes
way down uh by hybridizing grains to
fend off parasites and bugs and so forth
and as a result it's almost all
carbohydrates now and very little in the
way of protein and so this is why in the
livestock industry we had to come along
with soybeans to add to animal feed to
raise the prot protein levels because
grains greater yields in terms of tons
and bushels per acre doesn't have enough
protein for them and so we had to add
the soy beans to bring the protein level
up to satisfy the need for raising
livestock either for reproduction or
fattening in the feed lot for for steaks
and shops and so so the increase in
carbohydrates could that be an increase
in like cellulose it is partially an
increase in cellulose cellulose is what
makes a carrot pop when you you know
when you break it and you bend it uh
cellulose is what makes a stock of
celery stand up straight okay and isn't
cellulose pretty hard to break down well
it is and this is where all these little
bacteria and yeast and things in the
cow's room in that four that that's
actually the third stomach um does that
they have little enzyme systems that
break down that cellulose called
cellulase okay human beings don't have
cellulase and so we don't do a very good
job we don't have that big third stomach
with 40 gallons of all these bacteria
yeast fermented the stuff with cellulase
breaking down that cellulose right so
what happens when it's not broken down
what does that do to the Villi well uh
that alone won't do much to the Villi
but it can give you a soft stool or I
mean a lot of people use Fiber as
another term for cellulose fiber and
they use that to have a bowel mov it it
makes the the transition time the
movement time from the mouth to coming
out in the bowel movement in the toilet
shter okay and this is what helps people
that are constipated is that cellulose
uh that's what fiber is is cellulose
okay and so it can be medicinally useful
as long as it's a neutral type of
cellulose if it comes from foods that
cause um intolerances not allergies
necessarily but intolerances that can
create more problems and other
unintended consequences well explain to
us what you mean by intolerance because
this is I think a new term for most
people when most people think of food
allergies but we're talking about
something that's not blood allergy
allergic reaction that happens when
undigested particles get in the blood
it's something different you often call
it like a contact allergy yeah sure
exactly you've hit the nail on the head
there Blake um the the typical allergies
whether you're inhaling them you know
like dust and pollin and things they get
into your bloodstream through uh your
lungs and these large protein pollin and
pollins are essentially the sperm of
plants is what they are pollen is the
sperm of plants okay and it travels
through the air to fertilize the eggs
the flower is sitting there waiting
that's why bees go from flow to flour
taking the sperm from one flow into the
ovary of the other flow that's that's
how that works and um the pollen is very
high protein thing and we actually have
some great pollen products of pollen
burst right is it has flour pollen not
bee pollen and as a result it's less
allergenic than bee pollen cuz be poen
has B spit and BP that uh becomes a
sensitizing factor in its own right as
these large relatively large biochemical
protein or polypeptide products get in
your blood it sets up an immune reaction
and your body recognizes these proteins
as being eggs and cabbage and beef and
fish and shrimp so you become allergic
to them you set up allergies to them
because your body's trying to protect
you from this foreign Invader perceives
as a foreign Invader and that's because
well it's a protein and you're not
supposed to be able to absorb whole
proteins okay okay we're supposed to
absorb only simple amino acids otherwise
they set up these
allergies well intolerances are
different as you point out there are
contact things there a lot of people who
can't wear certain me Metals in rings
and jewelry and bracelets or watches or
eyeglasses go nickel will set up almost
like an eczema where that metal touches
that's a contact allergy another one I
like to use an example is poison ivy if
I have a a theater with a thousand
people and I test them for a poison ivy
allergy I guarantee you nobody in there
will be allergic to poison ivy because
they're not eating it every day and so
on on the other hand I guarantee you
they're all intolerant to poison ivy
because poison ivy actually produces and
releases a toxin to defend itself
against foreign Invaders that's it fends
off bugs you never see bugs eating
poison ivy right okay you never see
animals eating poison iy because after
one time they won't do it again and
that's its defense that defense that
intolerance to that toxin or that poison
or that contact poison that's produced
by the poison ivy it makes your skin
have almost an eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis like reaction now the same
thing happens when you consume Foods
you're intolerant to not allergic to but
intolerant to because this food will
produce a contact intolerance contact
allergy if you will you don't have to
absorb it to react to it right so it's a
contact allergy not necessarily just on
the skin but contact with the intestinal
lining yeah and I don't like to use
allergy because it's not a true allergy
and people well we tested you for a
wheat allergy and you're not allergic to
wheat but you're still going to be
intolerant to that gluten okay and so
you have to really use the correct words
here otherwise people say oh my doctor
tested me for wheat allergies and I'm
negative we can still be negative to
weat allergies is being tolerant to
wheat proteins okay two totally
different things before we go into
what's happening there with that um just
to reiterate we're seeing more and more
wheat and people think eating healthy
means eating whole grains and so we have
a lot more wheat weed in our diet and at
the same time with uh the decrease of
salt with it maybe we talk about the
minerals in the soil and fewer minerals
in the soil tends to be fewer enzymes in
the plants when we eat them and so
they're harder to break down do we see
that happen we don't require enzymes in
plants to break and that's a myth okay
we don't need enzymes in our food okay
because we produce our own enzymes yeah
if you're getting all your nutrients and
everything's perfect you're producing
all the enzymes you can eat everything
you eat without enzymes in it and you'll
be fine right but body has to in order
raw materials right and in order to have
the enzyme that breaks down wheat work
you need a pH of about you said 1.5 1 to
1.5 pH in the stomach that's correct so
super acidic environment what happens if
you don't have that strong of stomach
acid if you haven't been eating well
then the pepsin won't work it won't ad
just wheat barley Ry oat proteins or egg
proteins or fish proteins or clam
proteins or any kind of proteins down
into the simplest of amino acids so we
get undigested weat barley riono Protein
that's into the intestines you got it
now it becomes a dangerous chemical okay
it's like little slivers that go down
there and become a kind of and they
create it's not a mechanical thing okay
more than just a mechanical yeah and
slivers implies to me mechanical stuff
like splinters and right and microscopic
splinters and so it's not slivers so I
wouldn't use the word slivers it's
actually a protein it's a microscopic
droplet of protein okay so it hasn't
been digested it touches these villi and
what happens it's like poison ivy okay
this is like a toxin of poison touching
that viline it swells up and because it
swells up we've cut down the we've cut
down the ability of the food to get you
reduce the surface area right which
messes up our absorption plus when that
when that Villi swells it not only
swells on the outside to close off that
space in between the adjoining Villi but
it also squeezes the blood vessel on the
inside because the swelling also goes
the other direction okay on the inside
it shuts off that blood vessel so even
if you can partially absorb some of that
food it doesn't get into the bloodstream
because there's no blood in there
anymore there's no circulation and this
is why um you have problems in another
way when you have what's called celiac
disease uh The Villa actually die and
they will die because of cut off
circulation exactly okay and they die
and so now you're losing 10% 25% 50% 75%
80% 100% of your absorptive surface and
now your intestin are just a tube
there's actually Scar Tissue right
behind all those dead Villi trying to
protect you from the invasion of the
bacteria and acids and Alkali and all
this other stuff now when you've done
all of these autopsies on both people
and animals did you see this oh yes it's
very dramatic and very easily diagnosed
uh at autopsy or biopsy and so you can
actually feel it when you do surgery you
can run your hands down the small
intestines and you can actually feel
areas and this doesn't happen all at
once it's not like turning on a switch
turning off a switch like all your
intestines go at the same time a small
baby when they're born if the baby is um
sensitized to gluten the mother's eating
uh wheat and she can't digest them
properly and she has asthma and she's
got uh things like eczema and other
symptoms of celiac disease or iral bowel
syndrome or inflammatory bowel disease
all sort of colitis or Crohn's disease
these undigested wheat proteins barley
rye and oat proteins called glutens it's
a gluten category will come through the
stomach down in the intestine it will
actually touch those um Villi they will
begin to become and they they actually
act as a um a poison so those Villi
shrink swell up and there's Scar Tissue
that's farmed there and when this
happens you get it's almost again like
eczema on the outside and your
intestines will crack and seep fluid and
serum and stuff and it's a mess there is
that that leaky gut syndrome we hear
about it can be called leaky gut
syndrome is another name for it okay and
doctors will call it leaky gut syndrome
but they won't really make the
connection that is caused by this gluten
intolerance Okay so we've got
inflammation that decreases absorption
area and shuts off the BL the blood
supply to the Villi we've messed up the
absorption and you mentioned that these
are often characterized by a lot of
essential fatty acid deficiencies we
know essential fatty acids aren't
micronutrients they're macronutrients so
your body needs a lot of them well again
this doesn't happen all at once and
these these young babies might only have
one or 2% affected by this damage okay
and they have get what called K cic they
get kic and they're just uncomfortable
they're screaming and they don't want
you to touch their belly they're just
really sensitive and so the mother says
well my baby can't tolerate my milk and
they put them on a formula and the
baby's fine for a while okay but the
baby's been sensitized to this gluten
then now the baby now has a gluten
intolerance it was undigested wheat well
undigested gluten undigested wheat
barley ryer oat proteins coming through
the breast milk that sensitize the baby
okay so now the baby sensitized to it it
goes on formula it does fine it does
fine but then it gets grows up starts to
eat cereal breakfast cereal it starts to
eat solid food is weaned off the formula
on the solid foods and now it's it goes
through the same process again because
it's been sensitized your intestine has
a memory and say oh oh there's that
gluten stuff and it reacts Villi shrink
and the blood supply shut off and you go
through the whole thing again but it's
not an All or Nothing thing it'll be
patches particularly worse for the
intestines curve around because
everything slows down to get through
there so the contact is longer and so
you have patches of intestines that have
inflammatory bow disease and patches or
celiac disease and patches or Crohn's
disease different degrees of severity
all the same intestine but you might
only have 5% Afflicted in a baby you
don't really see much other than them
being kiky it would be the word and
they're tummies tender and all that kind
of stuff and then the baby say gets to 5
years of age and the baby's got rashes
and they develop asthma and they cannot
absorb things at this point when you
have say 20% 25% of your intestines
Afflicted particularly cholesterol and
particularly um omega-3 essential fatty
acids because these are large complex
molecules and they can't get through
this damaged
intestine do you mind just mentioning
briefly here I know we do it on other
recordings about cholesterol because a
lot of people don't understand that
cholesterol is an essential nutrient yes
cholester sure Blake cholesterol is an
essential nutrient it makes up a
significant portion of the cell wall of
each cell it makes up uh
95% of the steroid hormones in your body
from your adrenal gland from
testosterone estrogen
progesterone it's also necessary um as a
raw material from milin the fatty
insulation material in the brain and
some of the peripheral nerves and this
myin in the brain makes up 75% of your
brain weight and it's almost 100%
cholesterol and so somebody who would
say to me oh my doctor's jealous because
uh my um cholesterol without medication
is 90 they have advanced very severe
celiac disease or Ile syndrome
inflammatory B disease ulcer citis and
our Crohn's disease so the only time we
see cholesterol that's really low is
either if they're taking cholesterol
lowering drugs or they have an
absorption problem that is exactly right
which is a very very bad thing you do
not want your blood cholesterol down
below 220 you get down below 220 you're
in the danger zone more people die from
heart attacks when your blood
cholesterol is down below 220 than you
do when it's up to 220 to 270 in fact
the people on Earth who have fewest
cardiov vaster events or the innu the
eskimos above the Arctic Circle and
their cholesterols run 350 to 500 wow
and they have the fewest cardiovascular
events until they come down here and eat
like us and they have the same ratio as
we do as long as they're eating 90% of
their diet is red meat and fat um whale
meat and whale blubber walish meat wal
blubber seal meat seal blubber bare meat
bare fat they only eat 2% fish they're
doing great yeah but they come down they
get a lot of grains they develop
absorption problems and they're stir
frying and fire
frying exactly they fry stuff and and
they clog their arteries because of the
inflammation caused by the bad fats
contac in the artery walls and they get
Archer sclerosis now for the people
listening to this recording I know one
of the things that we often talk about
as a sign to how you can tell if you
have a cholesterol or an essential fatty
acid deficiency is if you ever go in a
room to get something and you get to
that room you can't remember what it is
you go to get you went to get that could
be a sign that could be a sign you can
also get cracks in your heels you can
have dry skin you can have eczema you
can have crack cuticles you can have
hang nails all all the you know splits
in your skin and you see this actually
all these things from gluten intance are
worse during the winter time always
worse during the winter time because our
bodies obviously need more essential fat
gases to keep the moisture in during the
winter time when it's cold and it's dry
change that might that might be a factor
but the main factor is during the winter
time you eat more pasta more toast more
oatmeal more pancakes more waffles
during the summertime you're eating more
fruits and vegetables because they're
available okay and so we change our
dietary pattern during the winter time
and so if you have a gluten intolerance
you're taking more gluten during the
winter time and the disease becomes more
severe dur so it's an increase of
irritance it's an increase of irritance
you got it so if we're talking about an
increase of irritance then maybe the
reverse would be true if we get rid of
all the things that are irritating the
the intestines then do the intestines
have the ability to heal themselves they
actually do just like your skin when you
cut your skin or burn your skin it's
able to heal itself it rebuilds itself
very quickly has a capacity to do that
your intestine has the same capacity so
if you go on a macrobiotic diet AKA
gluten-free diet and the macrob diet was
actually created during the
1700s u in Germany the Greeks 2,000
years ago actually knew about celiac
disease and they figured out that when
you give up wheat barley R and oats back
2,000 years ago and eat more rice and
corn and beans lentils Millet and so on
and things like that that the disease
went away all these problems went away
and then you started eating wheat barl R
oats again you had this problem well in
Germany they created this macrobiotic
diet which is also known as the brown
rice diet there's no magic in the brown
rice but it's the fact that you give up
wheat barley Ry and oats so somebody
wanted to go gluten-free one of the
suggestions you could make is look at
that microbiotic diet and not focus so
much on what you can eat but look at all
the great things you can exactly well
you look at the uh Chinese there's two
billion Chinese almost two billion
Chinese and very few of them in China
ever get celiac disease ear bowel
syndrome inflammatory botel disease
ulcer colitis and and Crohn's disease
because they eat rice and Millet and
they eat flax and buckwheat which is not
wheat and they eat sweet potatoes and
squ and those sources of carbohydrates
and the same thing in America the people
who are meaters the infamous meaters who
eat meat and potatoes they have other
problems but they'll never get celiac
disease because you only get celiac
disease when you cannot digest wheat
proteins right now there are some things
that I think make the celx disease worse
you talk about the bad fats the trans
fatty acids all of those partially
hydrogenated vegetable and I'm even
seeing fully hydrogenated vegetable oils
which is margin right so when those get
in there how do they affect the Villa
then well they turn into what's called
trans fatty acids or free radicals and
these are very egregious chemicals they
actually cause inflammation they in in
in of their own right they're very
inflammatory things and everybody
everybody is sensitive to trans fatty
acids heterocyclic amines are burnt
animal fats okay and then you can also
have acrylamides which are superheated
carbohydrates like toast and these
crispy cereals crackers that sort of
stuff and so if if you're frying
potatoes you're getting trans fatty
acids from the heated oils even if they
say well we fry our our french fries
without our oils do not have trans fatty
acids well as soon as you heat them it
converts them into trans fatty you may
not start with trans fatty acids but it
will turn into trans fatty acids okay
and so it's kind of a lame not quite
true advertisement so it's burnt oils
essentially it's heated oils just even
heated all don't have to be burnt just
heated and then you're also superheating
the carbohydrate and the potato so
you're getting a amides okay a double
whammy a double whammy and if you go the
other way and you're using animal fats
to fry things in okay which some of
those fast food places do because it
really tastes much better to fry
potatoes and animal fats you're getting
heterocyclic amines cuz you're burning
animal fats you'll get trans fatty acids
you'll get heterocyclic amines and
you'll get the acry amides all from
French fries that are fried with animal
fats and I know that's why you encourage
people if you're going to use any o oil
S type for in cooking that they use
butter and do it on low heat so the
butter doesn't turn brown that's correct
you cannot fry with butter I prefer that
you cook everything by roasting stewing
baking uh make soups out of things even
when you have vegetables you're going to
steam I will then put a pad of butter on
the steamed vegetables it is not quite
as hot as putting the butter in the pan
and heating it that way so when you
steam a vegetable uh you're looking at
steamed vegetables you put a pad of
butter on there and melts them that's a
much safer way to use butter I just
don't like cooking with butter except
soft scrambled eggs right and when I
soft scramble an egg I like to um put
the the skillet or the saucepan in a
very very low temperature that I can put
my hand on that saucepan before I put
the butter in there for 10 to 30 seconds
it's going to be warm but I can keep my
hand there it's not going to burn me
okay then you can put the butter and
it's not going to hurt it okay so we
have we use more butter we cook on Lower
temperatures and use water cook in water
cook in water okay and at the same time
we want to probably decrease the amount
is there anything wrong even for those
people that don't have CX is there
anything wrong with them decreasing the
amount of gluten in their diet see
here's the thing if you're eating a lot
of gluten if you're eating a lot of
grains wheat barley Ryan oats cereals
pancakes pasta breads uh poptarts those
kind of things you're in danger you're
in Jeopardy if you're restricting salt
because you cannot make as much stomach
acid and as a result the pepsin doesn't
work and then you cannot digest the
wheat proteins down in the simplest
amino acid so there large chunks of
gluten come down there and cause
problems let's talk about some of the
symptoms of that because I know we see
people with acid reflux or heartburn
that tends to be caused from low stomach
acid not high stomach acid that's right
and so when they say I have acid reflux
it's a misnomer it's an incorrect it's
actually Incorrect and doctors
perpetuate that because they want to
sell their Nexium and other um what
called protein pump inhibitors which
protein pumps is what's in what are in
these Chief cells that actually produce
the stomach acid and so things like the
purple pill Nexium they Po in those
Chief cells yeah essentially that's what
happens they poison the chief cells so
they can't make stomach acid okay then
initially you're going to feel pretty
good but 6 months down the line you're
going to wind up with all these
deficiency diseases you never had before
because even if you were supplementing
with those nutrients you cannot absorb
them because you haven't acidified your
stomach and without an acid environment
in your stomach you get bacteria that
lives down there and grows and you eat
and it eats and it burps and kicks the
produces gas when it ferments the the
carbohydrates and sugars it produces gas
which causes bloating burping belching
heartburn and all that kind of stuff
yeah and that's what causes like you
said the heartburn it it takes even weak
stomach gas in the esophagus probably is
is pretty uncomfortable over time yeah
and of course when you belch that up uh
that weak stomach acid it might be five
or six very close to
it's like tasting vinegar you just put
raw vinegar on your mouth and it tastes
like acid but it's a pH of 4 to six
right it's not one and so that's where
people get the idea that it's acid
reflux and it's really not it's not acid
enough and so things are able to grow in
there and ferment carbohydrates so if
somebody has had acid reflux you know
it's again a Mis Noma but if they've had
heartburn if they've had those things if
they've been using carbonated beverages
or head salt restricted diets is or even
using these alkaline Waters improperly
using them during meals okay drinking
carbonated drinks during meals so if
they've been doing that the chances are
pretty high that they've had undigested
gluten proteins in their intestines and
they've developed an intolerance that's
right and they cannot absorb minerals
properly they cannot absorb B12 because
that castle intrinsic factor only works
in an acid environment so there's many
many bad things that happen over time if
you don't have a stomach pH of one now I
know you look at people with essential
fatty acid deficiencies with eczema or
asthma and you've seen pictures of my
own neph in Japan and what happened with
him when he was young and they put the
steroid creams to try to deal with the
eczema get him on the essential
nutrients more essential fatty acids get
the mother off the wheat and things
change um but what are some of the other
symptoms I know you talk about people
with multiple diseases that are very
different disease like a Calcium
deficiency is the same time as they have
a copper deficiency is the same other
things that can be a sign of an
absorption problem absolutely and of
course you see this in a hair nail when
you look at a hair analysis which can
look at they say 30 to 50 different
mineral levels in your hair if they're
all below normal you know you have an
absorption problem because that's not a
natural thing some of them are going to
be in the right in the middle of where
you should be some are going to be a
little high some are a little low some
are in low normal some are in high
normal and so you know it should look
like a stock market chart but if
everything but if everything's below
normal if you're just kind of like a
flat line that means you're not
absorbing okay so you can actually use a
hair analysis as a non-invasive very
economical test now other things we see
is we talk about if you've got a lot of
bad bacteria in in your colon uh you get
a lot of smelly gas you can have sulfur
as gas because they produce sulfur
dioxide um and also uh the bad bacteria
produce waste products you know they pee
and poop and it's called bacterial
toxins and this is where you get food
poisoning if you have for instance a
stafl cacus um food poisoning it
produces a toxin is very very quickly
you'll be on your hands and knees
throwing up and having diarrhea you'll
be a mess headaches and just really feel
bad and it can wind up killing you um
and you can get that within hours after
to consume staf caka poison okay food
poisoning on the other hand Sal Manila
food poisoning usually takes 12 to 24
hours after you consume salm monilla
bacteria for them to produce enough
toxin to cause food poisoning and so you
can tell without even doing the culture
whether it's a staff or a salm Manilla
based on the timeline yeah the timeline
when you eat something and when the food
poisoning occurs what about copper
deficiencies do you see people with
celiacs disease and absorption problems
have a lot of gray hair is that common
well sure they're going to have a lot
more symptoms of copper deficiency iron
deficiency uh omega-3 essential fatty
acid deficiencies folic acid
deficiencies uh which can be very bad in
women who are in the age where they can
you know childbearing age um if you have
a folic acid deficiency even if you're
eating lots of salads you can have a
baby born with spinabifida if you have a
zinc deficiency because you cannot
absorb it you're eating you're
supplementing with zinc you can have a
baby born with a cleft pet or heart
defect you can have a baby barn with
Down Syndrome because you cannot absorb
zinc and so uh these things are
absolutely Paramount to have optimal
absorption of these nutrients and so you
have to pay attention to each digestive
compartment acid in your stomach
alkaline in your intestine healthy
bacteria defend off the bad guys in your
colon and it's uh actually a lot of work
to make sure all that functions properly
and everybody's happy getting all the
raw materials they need and keeping the
bad stuff away and this is where the
trilogy of books Let's play doctor Les's
pable doctor the passport Roman therapy
come in this is where the book
immortality comes in this is where the
book Dead Doctors Don't Like I mean they
all talk about these things sometimes in
segments and there's another section in
the book rare Ur bin cures which talks
about hair analyses and talks about how
when all the minerals on a hair analysis
are below the low normal line that means
you're not absorbing and you know I see
thousands of these a year and now we're
seeing tens of thousands maybe Millions
a year it's going up because people are
eating more grains and people are being
told more and more by doctors to avoid
so so that combination is very bad so if
somebody is using the 90s Central DS we
know if you give your body what it needs
it'll do some amazing things that's
correct okay so you're doing some
troubleshooting they're using it most
people are going to get results when
they absorb it but if they're not
getting results the first thing we look
at is are they absorbing it that is
correct so in addition to going
glutenfree and it's important that they
stay gluten-free so they keep their
absorption that's correct we often add
the an enzyme product to help break it
down and especially people that say
maybe they've had their gallbladder
removed and so they're not producing the
they're not storing enough enzymes to be
able to well they're not storing enough
bile bile okay okay that case it's not
enzymes actually it's bile it's kind of
an emulsin it's almost like detergent is
what it is bile is like a detergent and
it breaks down big Globs of oil and fats
and little Globs of oil and fats are
more easily absorbed so for those people
taking a a great digestive enzyme and
using probiotics those can also help
with people that are going gluten-free
to help give them the right environment
for the intestines to heal themselves
well by right environment you're talking
about digesting foods down properly
right but you still have to have the
proper pH in the stomach and the
intestines and you have to have some of
the pancreatic and intesti enzymes that
are coated so they don't get destroyed
and digested in the in the stomach which
is more acid right and so all the all
these factors have to come into play and
then of course our ultimate enzymes has
Ox bile in it to give you that um
ability to I call it the gallbladder in
the bottle because it has the ability to
as you point out give you the right
amount of body B when you have a meal
particularly a fatty meal now to know
how bile Works what I want you to do is
take and put some like salad dressing
oil or even corn oil or something like
that and warm dish water and it just
forms a coating over the entire kind of
like a blanket over the water surface of
the water and get this oil just equally
distributed take a couple of drops of a
liquid dish detergent and put in there
just breaks up into little beads like
BBS and just all breaks up that's what
bile does to the fats in your diet so
how many enzymes and how often should a
person take them well I like them to
optimally to take say two at the
beginning of a meal with a couple ounces
of water are ultimate enzymes which has
the ox bile the pepsin the betane
hydrochloric to make stomach acid it has
the enzymes from the pancreas got
pancreatic enzymes it also has plant
enzymes it has brolene from pineapples
and it also has a pan from the papaya
which are very nice enzymes plants we
don't need them on a daily basis but if
you have a digestion problem for a
support just like putting a cast on a
broken leg you're use as medically in
that fashion you don't need them all the
time if you don't have a problem because
you'll make your own enzymes what about
the floor effects how often and how many
should the person use the floor effects
I like to use the floor effects I like
to use the nightly Essence I like to use
even the triple treat chocolate which
has probiotics in it that's great to
probiotics too yes and you can use those
as often as you want they do not have to
be consumed with meals and actually is
better if they're consumed in between
meals because you have less stomach acid
so more are going to escape through the
stomach without getting digested and
killed now I've seen uh often times
people be encouraged to take say three
floor right before they go to bed and
three with breakfast right and that's
why we call nightly Essence nightly
Essence you're supposed to take it
before bed right okay great so in
addition to that this is again these
aren't Standalone products but they go
with 9 essential nutrients correct that
is correct now I do have to make sure we
say this when you have celiac disease
and again this is a progressive thing
it's going to get worse and worse and
worse over time when you get up to where
you're 20 30 years old and you got 50%
of your intestines Afflicted you're
going to have 20 diseases you're going
to have eczema you're going to have
asthma you're going to have perodontal
disease you'll be infertile low sperm
count you'll begin to get headaches
unexplained headaches you get low blood
sugar low thyroid you're getting bone
spurs you're getting Stones all this
stuff is happening you're going to 18
different Specialists because you can't
absorb those nutrients there's nothing
that says you can't have 50 different
nutritional deficiencies at the same
time now what are some of those
historical cases you know you talk about
a lot of famous people that a lot of the
audience is probably familiar with that
have had these absorption problems well
Karen Carpenter of course she had um an
eating disorder called anorexia well
anorexia is a
self-imposed restriction of consumption
of food because you feel bad when you
eat food and almost always is because
they have celiac disease and they feel
really really bad when they eat wheat
barley R oats and so they just give up
eating and they keep going downhill and
they'll eat they feel pretty good when
they're fasting or eating lettuce and
then they start eating Breads and whole
grains again because they know it's
healthy quote unquote and then they get
sick again they stop eating and so
there's this downward spiral they may
level off for a while for a couple of
months and then they start eating those
whole grains again they drop down lower
and over a period of years usually in
their 20s and 30s it will be really
seriously ill with anorexia and some
people can't give up eating and so
they'll throw up the food that's bulimia
to they realize that if I throw it up
then I don't feel bad but if I just eat
it and leave it go down through my
intestines it feels like somebody's
pulling a dry rag through my guts is how
they describe it to me now could obesity
also be a result of poor absorption oh
absolutely because sugar is a very small
molecule and you can absorb sugars and
get lots of calories in that fashion
but you cannot absorb minerals you
cannot absorb um essential fatty acids
you cannot absorb cholesterol and
mineral deficiencies are what cause the
insatiable Cravings that Munchies in
animals is called cribbing or Pica and
as soon as you're taking in enough
minerals that you can absorb all those
cravings and Munchies go away and you
lose the weight and Portion Control
becomes easy to accomplish but you have
to give up the gluten for your
intestines to heal to then be able to
absorb the minerals now are there
nutrients we can take to help the
intestines heal well glucogel is is a
again very good source of collagen okay
which is the connective tissue and so
it's a source of of raw materials for
the connective tissue part of the
intestine to heal you know the things
that the Vil sit on is a connective
tissue essentially it's like the
foundation of a house or a slab that you
build a building on okay and that's
that's what the connective tissues and
all these things are um actually welded
to that connect tissue okay and that
connective tissue when it gets irritated
forms deeper and deeper and thicker and
thicker Scar Tissue which makes it even
more difficult to absorb things through
that scarred tissue layer kind of like a
callus yeah it could be a callus
absolutely but if you quit irritating it
how long does it take for those things
to optimally if you're really really
good about staying away from everything
gravies and even making sure croutons
don't find their way into your salad and
you pick the croutons out there's still
Crouton dust in the salad or you go to a
health food store that sells bulk grains
and there's all somebody they're
scooping grains into a plastic bag and
then they throw that plastic bag on the
um belt that takes their their food to
the cashier then you put your food on
there or maybe you're a farmer and
you're gluten-free in the household but
your husband or son or somebody's been
outside in their clothes uh mixing
cattle feed that has wheat barley r or
oats in it and then they come in and
they throw their clothing in the laundry
with yours you're going to be constantly
exposed even though you think you're not
and so it's very very important to I
mean you got to be really gluten-free to
get maximum benefit but under optimal
conditions you're avoiding everything
that has gluten in it it's going to take
anywhere from 60 to 90 days to see
recognizable benefit and it might take
anywhere from 6 months to a year to get
perfect 100% healing okay with taking as
extra essential fatty acids would that
help speed that process of reloading no
but what it does do is make sure you're
absorbing more of them it's just a
matter of concentration the more
throwing at it the more get through and
so you can actually increase your risk
of stroke because the essential fatty
acids one of the things it does is
prevent abnormal blood clotting which
results in Strokes deep vein thrombosis
pulmonary amsm coronary thrombosis
thrombotic stroke and so if you can't
absorb Omega-3s it increases the risk of
increases the risk of stroke so this is
why people die from celiac disease and
that's one of the things I know with the
risk of stroke and heart disease that
you actually fought with the FDA so we
can say that increasing your omega-3
essential fatty acids decreases the risk
of heart disease you got it well is
there anything else that people need to
know um the basics are be on the 90
essential nutrients if you have
digestive issues you know stay away from
gluten yes adding some enzymes and Flora
can be good anything else yes I would
wean kids off of and and you hear
grandmothers will tell you well don't
give your kids Wheat until they're a
year old right you hear that kind of
stuff now that's because their little
digestive tracts aren't prepared for
those kinds of things but if uh if I had
my way nobody under 10 years old would
eat grains Okay so no instead of
Pancakes or breakfast cereals we'd have
more eggs our toast our pasta our
crackers and croutons and hamburger buns
and hot dog buns and muffins and cake
and cookies and all that kind of stuff I
would have them only eat like in
Oriental they're going to be eating
sweet potatoes and rice and Millet and
flax more vegetables more vegetabl
eggs for breakfast nuts nuts for snack
great fats healthy fats um very little
carbohydrates except for peanuts I don't
like peanuts because they have two bad
things one is a lot of carbohydrate they
also have a poison in them called apoxin
which causes liver cancer and liver
therosis and and can cause sudden death
if you get a big enough concentration of
apet toxins which is a byproduct of an
infestation of a fungus in stored
peanuts uh called ASP perillis
essentially bread mold and I know you've
actually had uh some research on that
bread mold and wasn't that one of the
wasn't that the cause of all of these
Bears across the world that were dying
in zoos prematurely yes well when Marlon
Perkins picked me to do that uh study to
do all these autopsies in the zoos the
first thing he told me was look we have
a problem with bears and one of the
things I want you to do is look at why
all the Bears around the world in zoos
are dying of liver cancer and they only
lived to be about you know 30 to 35 they
all die of liver cancer out in the wild
they can live to be 60 years of age so
what's going on there well I had just
learned about apoxin because it was very
bad year for soybeans and there wasn't
enough soybeans in America like in the
summertime to make turkey feed so you'd
have turkeys for Thanksgiving right and
so um people who are making turkey feed
for the turkey Growers used boatloads of
a peanut meal from Nigeria to replace
the the inability to get soybeans that
year cuz there's a drought or something
well it turns out all those uh shipments
of peanut meal from Nigeria were
infested with that um asilis mold that
bread mold and so it infested the turkey
feed with apoxin which is the poison
produced by this asilis and all turkeys
in America died of liver cancer so they
had to import turkeys from all over the
world to have enough turkeys for
Thanksgiving well that had just happened
when I got that position so I'm thinking
okay well maybe the aspila is the same
thing there maybe the apoxin same thing
and you can recognize affet toxin in
food by getting in a completely pitch
dark room absolutely no light and
getting a black light which is
essentially an ultraviolet light which
they use in Disco Tech they have all
those luminescent lights you know and
they really pretty yellows and oranges
and purples and greens and blues well
these apet toxins will fluores like that
so you can take a slice of bread that
just looks like Wonder Bread you get in
there in the dark and you put that UV
light on it it ill flues gold and yellow
and orange and green and blue it's just
very scary okay and so I started doing
that and I would write letters to all
these zoos and because we didn't have
faxes and emails in those days we're
talking about the 60s right and um I I'd
say well what are you feeding your bears
and you're talking about a th000 PB
animal a lot of expense to feed a bear
so they'd go to these thrift stores you
know bread thrift stores and get the
week old and two week old mold infested
bread and they'd pay him a nickel AOW
for it just to get something for it and
they'd Feed the Bears that well it's all
infested with the ASP regillus and the
affet toxins that's so we just switched
them over to dog food like dry dog food
in 50 lb bags and the L cancer and bears
stopped overnight and this was more than
just one or two zoos we're talking every
Zoo every zoo in the world because every
zoo in the world because every zoo in
the world fed Bears old moldy bread and
so what happened to the lifespan of the
Bears well now they live up to 50 to 60
now instead of 35 fantastic and so that
was a very quickie that was one I got in
there in the first couple of weeks I
figured that one out and said well this
isn't all that hard you know well can
Health be that simple for people health
is that simple Blake it is that simple
once you know the combination it's like
if you have a heavy duty combination
lock you're there with a sledgehammer
hitting that thing you can't open it
here comes a little three-year-old who
knows the three numbers right uh
07007 yeah and click the thing opens up
and the same thing with the secrets of
health and nutrition uh congestive heart
failure the most common cause of death
in Americans it's a simple thyon
deficiency vitamin B1 it's the terminal
event of berry berry thyman deficiency
now what do doctors do well they give
you all kinds of pharmaceutical and
drugs uh to regulate heart beat and
diuretics get rid of the fluid that's
collecting in your lungs and your chest
and your belly cavity and they give you
digitalis uh to make your heartbeat more
effective and then they put you on the
heart transplant list they give you a
heart transplant so you're looking at a
half a million dollars well all you have
to do is put people on the 90 essential
nutrients get them off of sugar which
aggravates the thond deficiency and you
give them something like the d-stress
capsules which um two capsules gives you
3,000 times the minimum daily
requirement of vitamin B1 not B complex
100 we're talking about 3,000 times and
so when people have congestive heart
failure I like to give them six of those
capsules a day so they're getting 9,000
times minimum daily requirement and so
you get and I can legally say this will
support and promote healthy
cardiovasular metabolism give the body
what it needs and it'll and heal itself
that's correct and so this is as simple
as it sounds people say it can't be that
simple I mean otherwise my doctor would
know about it well not really because
they're not trained I know from my
experience you know I was in primid and
there was no nutrition in primid and
they said in four years of medical
school you can expect 1 30 minute
lecture on nutrition with no test so
expecting the doctors to understand
nutrition the MDS to understand
nutrition is like expecting your plumber
to know how to fix your all the
computers or to do brain
surgery yeah it's just really tragic and
and of course medical doctors have such
credibility and respect and in many
cases they deserve that on the other
hand in many cases it's actually a fraud
because the doctors don't know the basic
stuff required by the human body of
which they're supposed to be in charge
and one of the things I love about this
Mission and the message is that you
don't have to be an expert to share it
you just have to learn how to share the
tools because I know that I could share
your CDs and it's more effective than me
personally going out there and trying to
tell somebody all there is about health
and it's easier for them to share it as
well and that's what we do to share this
message with people and hopefully help
America and the world exactly well we
can we can actually save America and we
can save the world Blake uh simply by
teaching people how to take care of
themselves because again there's no
insurance policy that will prevent or
cure disease when you pay for a health
insurance policy all you're doing is
betting that in the future you're going
to screw up somehow and you're going to
run up a big medical bill with doctors
and hospitals you're going to need a lot
of money to pay them
doesn't do anything to prevent disease
or cure disease that's your
responsibility that's each of our own
responsibilities people say to me well I
don't have to worry about I got good
insurance well no that's not quite true
it might pay the doctor when you get
sick but you're the one that's
responsible to prevent yourself from
getting sick well and especially it's
not just our health it's the health of
our families and our kids and that's
right and grandkids and great grandkids
I have to start speaking in those
terms all right well thank you so much
Dr W for your time any last uh words or
messages well just remember that if
you're not salting your food if you're
not digesting and absorbing your food
properly you could wind up by being
damaged by a serial
killer well take it from Dr well he's a
horse doctor as well as a physician and
you know every Farmer worth his salt
puts out a salt block for his animals
and we need the same thing for us
absolutely right thank you Dr well